[Music]
tag game bottom of the night at bat
Ricky here
[Music]
what did you do let's go
Ricky I've seen you out there swinging
that stick even when you're suffering
pain
but you can't play baseball you're gonna
get rid of killed
and you're gonna wind up with an injury
that you'll never get over God's Gonna
Give You a higher calling but all I want
to do is play when I swing that bad I
eat crippled no more
Ricky
he did four homers in one game
your bones are rapidly depleting it'll
be a miracle if you ever walk again you
seen this Major League tryouts you're
gonna paralyze him I don't need you
feeling him full of false hope he's my
son
Ricky baseball had to end eventually
time to figure out what you gonna do
with the rest of your life
time you ever talk to me like a man is
to tell me to forget the only thing I
ever loved
and into you he's special
how many miracles do you need
plan to join the
best hitters you're ever going to see
the bad like the cost of team wins and
money
it's all stacked against me if you don't
try you're gonna die inside I want my
dreamer back
all your hopes I cannot do this alone
three is your time Rick a
determination and sacrifices have come
down to this
foreign
[Music]